so what video ideas actually get
views and what are the best video ideas
to be creating on youtube
right now in 2021 to earn money
in this video i'm going to be breaking
down three specific video ideas and case
studies
that are actually pretty easy to create
and will not only get you more views
whether you're just starting or even if
you're further along
but i'm also going to be showing you
some really cool ways
for earning money with youtube that
really nobody talks about and so if
you're fired up smash the like button
and we're going to get right into this
video but
i don't know if you've been asking the
question you know can you still grow a
channel in 2021 can you still get views
in 2021
and the truth is absolutely like i don't
know if you've seen that over half the
people on earth now
use social media can you believe that
and there's actually 2.3 billion people
on youtube now uh crazy those are logged
in with the gmail account
and really the pandemic has caused
social media live streaming and online
video usage to rise
but here's where it also gets
interesting besides there being more
viewers
and the opportunity to get more views
there's also a massive rise
in earning money online and specifically
this article says
u.s e-commerce growth jumps more than 30
percent
accelerating online shopping shift by
near nearly two years what does that
mean
it means that people shopping online
because of the pandemic
locked down forced to shop online that
the amount of people
adopting e-commerce which simply means
like
online shopping accelerated by two years
so there's more
viewers right now on youtube and there's
also more people shopping online that
matters because as i show you the video
ideas
you're gonna see how powerful this is in
terms of more people
doing online uh purchasing things online
which means you can earn money
in multiple different ways including
things like affiliate marketing and i'll
explain what that is
in just a second and signalfire revealed
this this is crazy
that being a content creator has become
the fastest growing type of small
business
that's like a quote from their market
report like this is no longer a pipe
dream
that like your parents are like what's
the you want to be a youtuber
is that even a job you know what i mean
like you're trying to tell your friends
you're like
yeah like i'm trying to kind of
transition out of my job i'm trying to
you know build a home studio build a
battle station i want to be a content
creator
they're like why don't you get a real
job you're like dude this is a real job
what do you mean get a real job it's the
fastest growing type of small business
that's a fact and that's actually a
really good article to read from signal
fire
and you may have seen that the
ceo of youtube's report review revealed
that the youtube economy
is incredibly healthy and strong despite
the challenges of 2020
the number of new channels that have
joined the youtube partner program last
year
has more than doubled over the year
before and creators are building the
next generation of media
companies that impacts the economy's
overall success
according to an oxford economics report
youtube's creative ecosystem contributed
approximately
16 billion dollars to the u.s gdp in
2019
supporting the equivalent of 345 000
full-time jobs what the what
like the youtube economy the creator
economy
is incredibly healthy it's alive and
well so if you're making the right
videos
and you're connecting them to the right
monetization strategies there's massive
opportunity that article goes on
an equivalent of 30 000 jobs in the uk
15 000 full-time jobs in france
and so there's massive opportunities so
i know you want to get into the video
idea smash like we're going to jump into
this
and by the way if you were just meeting
my name is sean cannell this is coffee
with kennel it's been a minute since the
show has been on
where uh tell me what you're drinking in
the comments and we'll get to your
questions
as well as bring some guests on in a
little bit but let's talk about these
video ideas now
these are some practical video ideas
that i haven't really shared
uh before but we're gonna look up not
just video ideas but i'm gonna explain
some nuances with them and the first one
is best christmas laser lights it's
story time
and it's build your youtube channel time
so we're going to go here
we're going to look up best christmas
laser lights so the first video idea is
really doing a product review
but i'm going to tell you a story about
this video so this video
this video is uh
from 2016. okay so it's a product review
of some christmas laser lights from
2016. let me log into my account that
doesn't have that has youtube premium so
there's no ads
so here's the story so i
understand that youtube is a search
engine people are looking for
products on youtube people are looking
for product reviews product tutorials so
that's video idea number one
and not only that though you want to be
talking about the right topics at the
right time with the right title and the
right thumbnail and in this case
i wanted to be talking about something
that i noticed
at a local grocery store now the story
is maybe you've heard about these
christmas laser lights before
they're like these little kind of leg
projector lights
you know and you can project them on the
side of your house
um they're my favorite lights because
they only take about five minutes to set
up
and um that's because it took me four
minutes to actually find the extension
cords in my garage
now my wife hates them she thinks
they're ugly she thinks i'm lazy
and when i started using these lights
you know she lost all respect for me
but here's the deal is what happened was
um i didn't want to be like clark
griswold anymore from national lampoons
and like stapling lights on my roof and
trying to compete
like i just i wanted to work on another
thing i wanted to make youtube videos i
wanted to hang out with my you know six
month old son
but i was at the grocery store and i saw
that these lights were starting to
become mainstream
i saw him actually at a display and i
thought huh i wonder if anyone's made a
youtube video about that i wonder if
anybody's put out a product review or
tutorial about that particular product
and sure enough i went home i did my
research and my uh
keyword research and whatnot and so i
decided to make this video well here's
the case study of doing a
smart product review video this video
now also links so so number one it got
465 000 views here's a video idea that
actually gets
views a product review video and a smart
one though
that was posted at a smart time timing
matters posted around a smart trend
christmas happens every year uh you know
and people are looking for different
lighting
posted on a new innovation to an
industry
but also connected to affiliate
marketing now i don't really have
time to fully go into what affiliate
marketing is if you want to learn about
that i have a free class
and there's a link in the description
i'll tell you more about it later but
thinkmasterclass.com if you haven't
watched that the replays up for a few
days
and so but watch this in the description
down below
there's a kit.co link this is actually a
place where you can
organize multiple products but here's
actually a better example
you click this link it takes you over to
amazon.com
and this particular light now this is my
affiliate link so if someone purchases
this
light then i get a commission on the
sale this one's actually sold out
so what i actually do if you look higher
up here i update this
year over year i need to update it again
so i made a kit.com because this video
is like four or five years old
and on kit.co i should say kit.c
then you see these lights up here and
these are updated so each year i need i
didn't do it last year
check out all the best christmas laser
lights updated for 2019 so this year
i'll say check out all the best
christmas later laser lights for 2021
all right and it links over here and
then when someone clicks on these links
and they purchase this particular
christmas laser light i get paid
and um i get a part of the commission
when
i first released this video back in 2016
the video got probably like fifty
thousand hundred thousand views which
was cool
but it earned over four thousand dollars
in affiliate commissions
crazy i can't go into the full story i
talk more about it on the class
but that's the power of doing a smart
product review at a smart time
and this doesn't always happen but like
it's cool to see that year over year
this video has continued
to generate and it actually ranks in
search these right here are the ranked
tags i'm using vid iq to see that so
every year this video keeps getting more
views
and uh it's done remarkably well so
that's kind of like the first
video idea is to do a product review
around a trending time
of the year in this particular case you
know what are people shopping for for
back to summer back to school or
whatever
and then of course there's other things
good thumbnail good
good title different details like that
again i actually talk about that
um on my class called think master class
and uh we go more into details because i
want to give you a couple other examples
so the next video idea is similar you'll
notice that these all are all kind of
related to products because it is my
belief
that products are influencers what do
you what does that mean
means that a lot of people know kim
kardashian and a lot of people know the
canon m50 even if they don't know sean
cannell
like that people are looking for a
particular product they're
looking for laser christmas lights and i
just
got into the middle of that conversation
what conversation can you get into the
middle of
and what is a product in your niche
that's relevant maybe coming up on
summer or winter
maybe back to school or homeschool
supplies
or maybe a particular car review or how
to protect your car
a particular accessory for your tesla or
a particular there's so many different
opportunities and people are making
videos about whatever i'm surprised
people don't do more
videos that are product reviews or
product tutorials
well i'm not a product review channel
you don't need to be like whatever niche
you're in there's products in your niche
and that would serve the viewer that
subscribes to your channel
and so the next one is best greens
powder
best greens powder so this could be
the second video idea is really like
this meets a need
it meets a um you know a particular
um in this case it's in the health niche
now you if you search best greens powder
this is also powerful because this is
what's called a ranked video right so my
video it's four years old shows up here
on the first page
179 000 views again a
product review and
let me let me give you for number two
number one is a product that
is around a trending season this is an
evergreen product review what does that
mean not just that it's greens powder
evergreen i grew up in seattle
washington i didn't actually grow up in
seattle i grew up in arlington
washington a very rural community that
was not urban at all
but nobody knows where arlington is they
know seattle so i just say seattle
because it's a reference point
okay we have evergreen trees up there
what does that mean they're green all
season long
they don't get leaves and lose leaves
they're always green
summer winter fall spring so an
evergreen video is relevant all year
long now imagine
january new year new you come on trying
to lose a little weight
try to get a little healthy healthier
try to eat a little less you know
pork pulled pork trying to drink more
green juice powder
sorry vegans listen uh best green juice
powder
organifi green juice review so this came
out in may
2016 video ideas that get views a
product review
now i also was saying that these videos
are easy to make i shot this video in
front of my window
like i just sat there now don't get me
wrong
i thought through it i always like to
think through of a good intro
think through i organize my thoughts i
really don't shoot from the hip
but it's there's no like b-roll there's
no extra angles
there's no drone footage there's nothing
you know
a little bit of editing jump cuts 180
000 views so pretty good
may 9th 2016 this video came out and
this video continues to get views to
this day now what's interesting
is i didn't even mention that video
before with 500 000 views
probably has earned 2500 bucks maybe
five grand this video has earned a
thousand dollars in youtube adsense
ah but what's interesting and i told you
it wasn't just video ideas
that get views but video ideas that make
money this video
you can check out my full organifi
review here or
check out the full link this link right
here this is an affiliate link
but it's not to amazon okay what does
that mean
it means that this links to the organifi
green juice
and if you're new to affiliate marketing
you know the way to do it with integrity
in my opinion is to recommend products
you love and use
my mom my mom my wife who by the way i
lost her respect with the christmas
lights but after i told her we made
four thousand dollars from affiliate
sales she was like
okay i respect you again you know i like
those lights too in fact i love those
lights
she calls me she's like why do you have
so many elixirs and potions and
biohacking stuff
like this is an overflow of my passion
like so
i like to travel i like to stay healthy
so i drink this green juice on the road
my friend louis house told me about it
years ago
so i discovered most things have an
affiliate program
i discovered the product now what's
interesting and so i was like let me
make a video about it after i had tested
it well you can see
to get uh boxes of these right 104 bucks
34 bucks 69
uh and then what people can do is they
can subscribe to these and this has
changed over the years i mean literally
this video has been generating money for
uh years now but um
this one video has earned over ten
thousand dollars
in sales of this organifi green juice
powder over the last four years
one video because it was a smart video
idea
listen that also meets a need people are
looking for the best greens juice powder
they're looking for
maybe you're not looking for it so
here's my question what are you looking
for
what is the people that you're making
your content the videos for maybe that's
why you're not getting views
because you're making videos that nobody
wants to watch maybe that's why you're
not getting views
because you're making videos and
answering questions nobody is asking
maybe that's why you're not getting
views because you're just talking about
like here's my thoughts for the day i
was
answering solving a problem because
people are like what's the best greens
juice i'm like well listen
i buy all kinds of them i test a lot of
them here's here's one
check out link in the description down
below so it actually meets a need it
helps somebody it serves somebody
affiliate marketing done in integrity
should be a win-win-win-win-win
because the brand wins
youtube wins because they got views
that's how they put ads on the videos
uh the person who purchased the product
wins because now they're drinking green
juice they're healthier
you know and then i win because i made a
small commission in the process
but what's interesting is on amazon you
only make one to ten percent
on a sale on this product i make 30
percent
and if somebody subscribes i get
continuity so if every month they get a
box i get 30
every month until they as long as they
stay subscribed if they stay subscribed
for 10 years
and the affiliate program's still going
i'm still earning money that's where
that 10 000
came from and it's it's it's gone down
now it's about
200 bucks a month 300 bucks a month
so it's still you know that's still like
2 grand a year it's probably 2 500
a year that video still earns and it's
kind of old right and i've
i've also pivoted niches you know i've
i've been talking more about tech and so
on and so forth
but i'm very it's very important to me
to always show you that like
i'm not like a youtube guy that only
succeeds on youtube by talking about
youtube like i've done this in all kinds
of different niches
we've helped people in all types of
different topics and i'm
super passionate about being a player
coach that's like done this
in multiple different ways with multiple
different income flows so that's the
second one
the first one is like do a product
review based around a trend
a season the second one's do something
that's evergreen because people can
watch this video 24 7 365
the moment that the the student is ready
the teacher appears
when someone has that question of like
man what is the best out of the green
powders
you know they can they can discover this
video
and the third one is probably like the
most practical
that you've seen before cheap led light
for video
smash like if you're getting value out
of this video so
if you type in like this is this would
be like a
very specific uh product review
video it would be the idea and
i think the idea here is also a couple
tips cheap is a good niche a lot of
times people
a good sub topic people want the most
affordable option
what is a budget option what is a cheap
option so there's the thing itself
hey what's the best video light for
youtube
okay good then there's also like what is
the best affordable video light for
youtube okay
what is the best affordable light for
youtube or the best
led video light for youtube under 50
the under like we teach asq answer
specific questions
so i actually was wondering like
here's one here's three years ago 325
000 views
the newest one which is cool is is the
second top-ranked video
and it's got 71 000 views so notice the
title
best cheap led video light for youtube
under forty dollars
so question of the day tell me in the
comments
what is one product review video you
could do in your niche
what is a season coming up that's
relevant to your niche and what kind of
product could you review or do a
tutorial on
what is maybe something that's relevant
year round people in your
topic your niche your niche are always
looking for it
and then maybe as you're answering the
question if you have any ideas have it
come up what's like a very specific
question you can answer
you know best thing in your topic
affordable thing in your topic
under a specific dollar amount in your
topic and again what ends up happening
is through affiliate marketing
if somebody clicks this link um they can
uh purchase this product and you know
we've
been hitting major numbers in terms of
how much money we earn with this and
hear me i started as a small town kid
college drop
out in my bedroom making videos uh
and my first affiliate commission was
two dollars and 12 cents
but maybe you saw that cnbc did like
this mini documentary
on me about the month we hit 40 grand we
kind of hover around like 30 35
profit in terms of just amazon and we're
a part of about 20 different
affiliate programs um but um if you've
never seen this it's definitely worth
checking out it's a super
um entertaining kind of video and a
huge privilege that i was featured on a
little mini documentary by cnbc
but let me know what's a product review
video that you could do
in your uh niche and that would be
relevant and listen that can not only
here's a little clip of it
that can not only uh grow
your audience because here's the key
think about what these videos are doing
they've gotten hundreds of thousands of
views 400 000 views
they have grown lots of subscribers new
subscribers
they've made money with adsense but then
they also make money with affiliate
marketing and some of program
programs beyond even uh amazon
and so the reality is if you want to
talk about win win win win win
for your youtube channel your youtube
empire that you're building your youtube
business
you want to be thinking they can do all
those things all at once
and serve people in the process like
it's pretty crazy
and so check out links in the
description down below and specifically
i know i rushed through a lot of things
today
um but uh check out thinkmasterclass.com
if you want to learn a little bit more
about this link in the description down
below go there if you enter your name
and email that's where i'll send you
i did about a 90-minute training where i
go deep
setting up affiliate marketing other
ways to earn money
and also the big question of course you
know how do you really structure these
titles
optimize the videos come up with the
right topics but i hope this video
served you smash like and check out
thinkmasterclass.com
for more details on that um we're back
man coffee with kennel hit the like
button and uh
uh i would love to uh
we're gonna bring some people on and
answer some of your questions we'll
bring some guests on
and i'd love to answer some questions if
you're in the chat throw up four
question marks before
and after your question and i'll be able
to throw your
question on screen man dad life out here
sean bradley's like six months
and two weeks old probably
[ __ ] like he's not talking but he
means like talking he says
um those are his words and i'm like dang
it it's no it's
da da da da not ma he definitely said
mama
first uh and he hasn't said that at all
and so uh we'll be okay with that but
here we are
little uh little easter flow there's
sean bradley
and uh that's my life that's that
basically sums it up right there
is um that's what every day's like
and uh there's the little guy there's
his mom
sonia my wife of 15 years
our dog sophie we're down one i know
people have been with
you've been a part of like the think
community for a while you're like
where's rosie
she passed away on thanksgiving day 2019
and so we miss her dearly
we want to get a new dog or new dogs but
what we got was
a baby and i'm not trying to get like
that much complexity going on in my life
all at uh at once and so um
uh the sean bradley man and his mother
and so uh anyways hope you're doing well
how have you been
what are you sipping on what questions
do you have
about uh youtube throw up the question
marks
and um we'll uh we'll get rocking
tronus asks any gaming video ideas and
harvest
havoc's asked just wondering if you
could give some video tips
for gaming well first and foremost i
um you know full disclaimer i'm not
i don't have a gaming channel besides
the channel you don't know about in a
popular niche
that's a faceless channel um
and i would throw out a couple things
number one
um this is kind of just a stream of
consciousness
idea on gaming uh different is better
than better
we did an interview with a guy named
skip the tutorial
and he started to do like challenges
like um
he would play through punch up punch out
using only verbal commands on whatever
nintendo system that was
the new punch out version um he would
use like no hands and just voice
commands in minecraft or something
um i also think that adding as much
editing and value
i did play through final fantasy vii
remake
and so immediately had a bunch of pain
points how
like what's the best material how do i
beat this boss i was living on youtube
like
through certain bosses through trying to
set up the material on my weapons
so you really can do search based
tutorials and anything that's like
five hacks or seven things you need to
know getting started with the game
i know that kind of stuff could be
really helpful um
obviously personality are you going the
entertainment route and you're trying to
be personality and entertaining
are you going the helpful educational
route and trying to help people navigate
through games
are you building compilations out and
just being like best kill shots head
shots and fortnite or something
the other interesting thing is that you
can also do like
the the monetizing side like i we've had
some of our students that did like best
gaming mouses and started making money
with affiliate marketing like comparing
gaming mouses
setups gamer tutorials but what's also
interesting is gaming
you maybe saw the article i think it was
a hundred billion hours of content
watched the verge did a report on
youtube alone not just twitch or
anything else
and you looked at roblox went public
like
what the heck are we talking about and
so there's people who
do faceless channels around my minecraft
roadblocks other things
where like i think the misconception is
that you even have to be playing the
game
as opposed to like the seven craziest
moments
of some famous uh minecraft player
and you're using fair use now that's a
conversation for a
whole nother day but i think the
punchline of all of that
is that um you got to think different
come on think
you gotta maybe think outside of the box
and not just necessarily
get on and do like two hour streams of
you playing i don't know what you're
doing but
you know there's and and i think that
illustrates a
bigger message to all of us
that sometimes we can get discouraged in
our niche
we like feel like there's no good ideas
all the good ideas are taken
i don't know what kind of content to
create you just gotta you gotta get a
bigger
you gotta think bigger you gotta get
more strategy think
you know i am not suggesting that you
can win on youtube in 2021 by playing
checkers
but i am suggesting you can win on
youtube in 2021 even if you're starting
from scratch if you're playing chess
if you're playing chess that means
you're more strategic you're thinking
about your next five to ten moves
you're thinking about smart video ideas
you're thinking about smart trends and
times of the year
you're thinking about how you're
positioning yourself if you're playing
chess
you're not just playing randomly scatter
shot you're playing to your strengths
you're playing to opportunities you see
in the market
you're looking at the landscape and then
you're making your decision
of how your channel is positioned the
games you're playing
the content you're producing the way
you're titling them
your thumbnail strategy you just gotta
be playing chess
to win when it comes to gaming in 2021
hope that was helpful evan my man we got
evan on the coffee scandal show
tell me about your channel and uh where
are you from
hey sean i'm from chattanooga tennessee
actually
and uh so southeastern united states um
first of all thank you so much for for
your influence and uh
my wife and i have learned so much from
you for our channel
uh she is a free travel agent and so we
have a channel
uh for her business that's her primary
it's called uh youtube.com
ginger mmt short for marvelous mouse
travels
so youtube.com ginger mmt
awesome all right tell me about it um so
we use it
as our primary marketing tool and um
oh you said so how do you make money if
she's a free travel agent then tell me
about
business model well so that's a great
question
a lot of people say come on get get real
seriously she's free well actually she
is
um so her primary uh
areas of expertise are disney
destinations
uh universal parks and resorts um
sandals all inclusives and cruises
a lot of people don't know it but
actually uh for example if you book a
disney world vacation for example with
her her services are free it is no extra
charge because
whether you book through her or
straight through disney world they
actually disney will actually build in
the cost
of a travel agent into the price you pay
them
and so you're paying for the travel
agent whether you use one or not
and it's essentially affiliate marketing
she's basically
she's a middle woman and basically she's
helping him and does she have a link
does she have to do it over the phone
or uh she she can there's a
that's called dta disney travel
agents.com they can access it and go
directly in
uh and all her help is free she helps
with dining reservations everything like
that
and so you pay disney and then disney
just gives her the commission
that they had already built into their
price so you're paying for
her help whether you use her or not
might as well get what you're paying for
you know
and so uh that's why it really is no
extra charge to use her services
um and so we use it as a prime the
youtube channel is the primary marketing
tool
um it's interesting that you're talking
about affiliate marketing because we've
been trying to figure out
how to bring that into the youtube
channel we've thought about maybe like
uh once a month do a video about like
travel product of the month or something
like that
um maybe that could be a way that we
bring in the marketing
element your affiliate marketing of it
she does have a kit store
and um she's got recommended travel
products on that
um but any any advice you can give any
any
uh thing that you see that could be
improved i'm all
ears because you're the expert awesome
yeah i love it
um okay so you know a couple things
let's just kind of check it out here i'm
gonna check these videos out
okay
[Music]
hi everyone thank you so much okay so we
got the bracket there you are wing tree
barbecue
i had chicken guy being beat in the
second round
of other helpful stuff so a couple
thoughts so i saw this style of video
i'm not a huge fan of the thumbnails of
these brackets
just because they kind of they're busy
uh they're very niche i see
they're doing like all right i think i
always go back to success leaves clues
and i know that not as much time has
passed since some of these older videos
but none of those brackets are anywhere
near giving you the most views
um if they accomplish a purpose i would
like to see the brackets thumbnails
change a little bit
okay i think these full tours clearly
this one's crushed hi everybody it's
jinger with marvelous mouse travels and
today we're going to continue
our tour of disney's value resort this
is phenomenal
of course people want to see this they
want to dream with you they want to make
their plan
does she give a good call to action to
her services then
she does you know it's interesting that
you mentioned that so that video is by
far most popular video
um she started really emphasizing a call
to action
about a few months after we released
this video because that's when we found
vra
yeah and um and so then we learned okay
so we need to really be adding in a call
of action at the end and
in any of her videos basically from like
two months after this and on
it has it in there um man
that's i mean that's a good lesson too
and of course i'm you know super
grateful you're part of the vra
community but it just goes we call it
kind of like the oprah moment
and you're gonna have more oprah moments
but it'd be this idea that like if you
were gonna write a book back in the day
when oprah had her main show
and you got a chance for her to come on
and be in like oprah's book club and
you're like
all right so tell me about like your
your you know your new book and you're
like
well it's on my computer i don't
actually have it in my hands oh can
anybody go to the website and sign up
for the
well the website's not really done oprah
but like and you'd get out this moment
but you would
you'd miss it you know what i mean like
and you never know what video is going
to blow up and obviously you're seeing
that but like
thinking that's why the power of getting
a good framework getting the right
strategies getting the right things in
place and i think the lesson to me
is to also work on recreate recreating
some of your greatest hits
i mean this is a two-year-old full tour
uh i would definitely
recreate uh head back down and where are
you guys based i mean so you have to fly
out each time to go to the park then
you either go to the coast or what we
don't uh we're about
it's a nine hour drive and so a lot of
times we'll wake up early in the morning
get on the road and get down there by
like
noon or one o'clock something like that
okay great
so so yeah i mean i would i would make a
plan to just go
dominate and you know literally as we're
strategizing together
if i'm you i'm gonna do a couple things
one i'm gonna do a reopening series
reopening is hot right now because it's
like what are the reopening things the
reopening tips you may not even have to
go there to do it you may be able to
pull some footage and some
photos offline some stuff from the the
website
number two i like to batch produce stuff
i know you know that from being a vray
so i like to never make just one video i
like to think about how i can make like
25. so i would literally think about
maybe
the full tour video and if possible of
course um
you know time and whatnot but if i could
get a hotel for a couple nights
and really get like three months of
content you know
going and when i'm also then
doing the disney full art animation
resort like uh
15 minutes i definitely call it action
at the end but i would do it throughout
it doesn't have to be intense but
she is letting you know that it's
marvelous mounts travels right up front
um but you know the type of things i'd
be doing is why
you're at a certain point in the tour i
might say you know one of the things
that i help people with
is really figuring out the best day plan
for them
you know if you want more information
about that check out the link in the
description and you can you know fill
out a quick survey but
the thing is because sometimes what
happens with and so like throughout the
video
not every minute on 15 minutes but i
definitely do at least like three or
four
where it's super relevant because
there's no doubt about it even this is
what's called
seeding before like
uh you get to the call to action at the
end you're also just
seeding you're planting seeds along the
way that are
some of the mindsets and things that the
viewer would need to know to maybe even
work with ginger
one of the myths might be oh if i work
with gender it's going to cost me more
you know what what i love about you're
just you're
on a thing with like captain hook and
you're like you know
and what i love about working with
people is i'm able to help people
make their disney experience twice as
good and it doesn't even cost them any
more money like it's really cool
and sometimes you might even say that
stuff without a call to action because
the whole thing is an experience where
someone is getting to know ginger so
then once it happens at the end
you know they're even more like ready
that's the power of youtube is you have
a chance to get to know like and trust
somebody
before like hey do you want a travel
agent so
those are a couple ideas and you're
exactly right because she's actually had
people
who message her and say i know this is
the first time
i'm talking to you but i actually feel
like already know you because i've
watched them in your videos so that's
cool that you said that
that's super cool so i think that um i
mean those are some really good ideas
that you could get started with the
channel is amazing
you guys are doing really good but again
and i know we've been on lockdown and
stuff's been crazy
all of your best performing videos don't
seem to be as much as
like again the bracket i just had this
my gut thing is i'm just not a huge fan
of the
the brackets um is this part of disney
these
biltmore estates is that like on the
property or next to it or something
it's not it's actually um she can also
book that destination it's in north
carolina we just went over there for a
couple days and we just did a vlog like
tour of the biltmore estate that kind of
thing
and so i mean yeah you can you can
divert from things
but that to me that's like
if i'm going from dabbling to dominating
i see you guys are serious about this
but i'm thinking i'm planting my flag
disney
i mean is it sandals cruises universal
or disney did you
did you break bran there evan did you
break the brand uh
yeah it's all four she can book all four
destinations primarily
it's one of those four it's not no
that's true that's that's a good point
i mean you can do it but that's where
like
and there's a certain i mean again i
think you could experiment these are
great leave them up let them do their
thing
but man it's the disney stuff i could
see the universal stuff that makes sense
to me
maybe disney cruise for sure and i'm
just thinking about
what's my annual schedule so i'm headed
to disney for three four five days to
get a ton of videos in the can
i'm also making a list of videos that i
don't actually have to be in disney but
i'm pulling in b-roll
fair use content some footage from you
know disney's announcement about what
reopening is
you know you can react to videos you
could do a video like this in stream
yard
and react to playing disney's i was just
playing her video with audio
different things like that that keep
building along the same promise
and then of course you maybe choose
what's most lucrative um of course the
passion is disney but
i mean is biltmore as you know
is it all the same in terms of her
commission it's it's definitely not as
high as disney and universal
your your history different ways of
making so
from this conversation do you feel like
you have some stuff to work with to kind
of build out a battle plan for
absolutely for the next couple months to
just keep growing
absolutely yes awesome i appreciate it
thank you you're the man sean we really
thank you a lot
i appreciate you grateful that you're
part of our community evan thanks for
coming on
thank you my friends
what was your unlock there's a good
conversation with evan did you learn
anything
that you need to apply to your channel
man staying on brand you can always
divert from the brand but also
you want to stay on brand and remember
success leaves clues
go to your most popular videos right now
if you've been posting videos for a
while
and if you have some of these really
these bangers from two years ago
remake them make the part two make the
update
break it into sections you know um i
like
i like the idea of like part one part
two disney's art of animation resort
uh or or also man if you hit
world i'm assuming tennessee is more
towards florida i would imagine so we're
going to world
you also got four parks shoot we need we
need some time on the clock like you
have
i don't even know what they are but you
got epcot you got other things
all kind of search based stuff but once
you really find the thing that's working
double down on what's working
success leaves clues and double down on
what's working
and then connected to smart strategies
as well
in terms of like i love this vision
maybe you didn't even know that you can
be a travel agent without charging
people any money a free travel agent
think about how you can connect that to
different monetization strategies
today's
uh coffee with cannell is brought to you
by
think masterclass dot com
and uh if you we have i just recorded a
brand new live class the replay is up
for a few days
we go a little bit uh deeper on some of
this stuff
on the screen you can see the url
there's a link in the description down
below
if you have a question fire off some
questions we have a couple more guests
that are coming on
uh in a second here and uh
and i'm gonna answer your questions in
chat throw up four questions before
and after uh the question
so how do you niche down with the
fitness channel and
i am monetized now but i'm stuck
so i mean ways you can niche down
is the niche within a niche i get that
things like crossfit are huge
but crossfit's already a niche within an
inch obviously
peloton is on a whole other level have
you noticed that it's like there's not
even bikes anymore now
it's the app now they're like coaching
you while you run
so you can hop into a movement of course
there's a lot of peloton competition
but you want to move where things are
moving keeping it moving
so how do you niche down in a fitness
channel um
go deep and and do all things peloton
how do i hack the app on peloton
how to make your bike more comfortable
best seat cover for peloton
i don't even have a peloton i was making
some stuff up uh best shoes
for peloton um how to overcome when you
want to quit peloton how to save 10
on your peloton membership best peloton
membership
program are the weights really worth it
or should you just get the bike peloton
hacks don't buy the bike just buy the
app
buy a bike off amazon top three cheap
bikes off amazon
that uh can work with the peloton app so
you don't have to pay for their
overpriced bike
bada bing bada boom man let's hit it
from every different side
now keto is a niche you know
bodybuilding is a niche you can you can
niche down on the
type of person it is skinny guy workouts
uh losing weight workouts obese workouts
uh you know yeah plus size workouts when
my friend tulin
is a plus size fitness coach so the
modifications that she does in beachbody
help you in that particular circumstance
these are all kinds of niches
and that's really the key even in the
niches of the niches
there might be competition but then what
i want to encourage you with
is persistence and tenacity and strategy
then it's a matter of posting smart
videos consistently a lot of people
i'm calling you out that's why you're
part of think because i'm here to say
have you been consistent and have you
been keeping your quality consistent
you gotta have a good title man you
gotta have a good thumbnail on there you
gotta have some good content on there
you gotta have some good research on
there
you gotta really put the work in and
then keep showing up and put out quality
work consistently
because youtube is partly a numbers game
so i just listed off
all these pelleting videos that you
could do or whatever fitness niche your
thing is
you put out your next 20 videos and
three of them are doing remarkable
remarkably well you put out your next 60
videos
and two of those just broke a hundred
thousand views
and now are getting you to a subscriber
growth
where your base library is doing a lot
really well
got a couple hundred thousand viewed
videos but now every single one of your
videos is getting like 2 000 views
and with numbers smaller than that you
can be
in a highly profitable autonomous
youtube lifestyle you know that's what
we teach i hope you're subscribed on the
channel here
because we're always helping you figure
that stuff out but like you don't need a
huge audience
if you have the right audience so i hope
that helps that's a few ideas around
uh some fitness stuff shout out to
coconut pete
thank you so much for the super chat uh
today and uh we have got
hey what's your name and uh what is your
channel and question today
um actually robert i feel so embarrassed
because i just removed my makeup
and my wig out and at the moment i own
my computer i saw you guys i was like
i don't believe i can find you today um
so
i have to run to go and get i hope i'm
not looking crazy or crazy on my phone
um actually what do you say
you look great what is uh your name says
think marketing
which is the channel we're recording
this on but what
um what is your name or your youtube
channel
it's garand stevie can you send me a
private uh send me on the private chat
yeah um sorry guys i don't know how i
look
you look great yeah that's a cool title
garage tv
okay what's your question how can i help
oh my god that's how i look on the
television
i just came to my television right now
actually i have recorded
oh i can't find you anymore yeah can you
hear me
i can't how can i help oh my god she's
crazy
can i go off off off camera because this
is an embarrassing one
okay yeah yeah not a problem not a
problem
thank you so much for coming on um
awesome fun times coffee with kennel
smash
like if you're loving life and uh
shout out to uh grantstvaranztv
and uh hop on sometime when you've got
the details that matter most to you all
lined up for
the episode uh with that we're going to
hit up
gearjunkie35 oh no
we got a little echo we got a loop i
don't know if we're going to be able to
work with this
do you have like uh some headphones or
something how's it going
okay oh shoot
we're struggling over here on uh on uh
coffee with kennel hey what's going on i
got you sean what is that
good to see you how are you hey you're
doing well on yourself
i'm doing amazing fun times coffee with
kennel
hey um so the channel is uh intermittent
fasting with ryan
and the question is so you've reviewed
it before i really appreciate everything
you'll do
great uh great podcast this week um
i'm gonna be hitting that up for sure
looking at writing a book at some point
i'm in the weight loss niche
so here's my question um
so the channel intermittent fasting with
ryan i
i am doing um i'm going after the key
word
what i eat in a week through my research
one of the questions that i get all the
time is you know what are you eating
so i turn that into my show every week
i'm showing everything that i eat
there's a lot of search volume around
what i eat in a week
and fairly medium competition but my
question is this is
if you were to look at that search term
there are no guys that come up anywhere
near the top so i'm wondering is that
because
that's an opportunity or because there's
not a um
there's not a demand for it you know
what i mean
most of those views on those videos are
coming from external i'm very active in
some facebook groups on reddit
um i'm still working on browse and
suggested from youtube
but fairly active in some facebook
groups so able to drive you know a few
thousand views
external only for the most part sure
so i mean that's a great insight there
think community to think about
is to do your research so you find kind
of a video i did you find kind of a
theme you hit the search bar
you start going deep on it you go oh
and the key word here is intent um
we we talk about this all the time at
think media like what is the
intent behind the search term
like if somebody was like how do i
record my iphone screen
is it a whole bunch of 13 year old kids
that want to do that hack because
they're playing a particular game on
their iphone
like who's the person on the other side
what's the largest desire what's the
psychology of the viewer what's the
intent behind the search term
and sometimes we can find incongruencies
there ryan i don't think that's
necessarily the case here but you've
definitely
to me you've probably found that okay
the intent is maybe women looking for
women who knows men looking for women
but not necessarily as many guys but i
would still argue that it's
it's a massive opportunity because you
could become
the the big fish in the small pond um
and it is working
it's also working in regards to external
in the group
i mean one thing and we may have talked
about similar themes before when you
were on
the show but one thing that i just look
at is i'm just like this is just working
i mean i've
we've gotten to kind of have a couple
touch points on your journey and you're
growing subscribers
you're hustling with the videos your
views are up 21 000
if it's external like who cares like
that's great like
you're you're grinding you're getting
there and and you were always just one
video away
from things breaking out and from you
becoming and
and what i would say is
what you are doing but what i would say
is
don't just go after what i eat in a week
but also keep going after different
options
exactly yeah so that's where you know i
kind of got away from that for a little
bit
um and here in the last three weeks i
have started getting back into some
ass uh answer specific question videos
because a video that i did three months
ago um
can you have diet soda while
intermittent fasting
is now ranking you know 250
people 200 views in the first in the
first
month or two and it's now just hit 1200
views that's pulling in
40 views and three subscribers
every other day yep yep so i'm getting
back into so the answer specific
questions
i got away from it i'm getting back i'm
doubling down on it i'm gonna do one or
two videos a week i'm batch producing
doing those you know five minutes
because
down the line that's how people on
youtube are gonna find me is this
is through the you know it's what vra
teaches
well 100 and and and i would add to that
i would say they're gonna find you from
all the above
i actually just want to affirm your game
plan right now
and fuel it even more the hustle and the
facebook groups and what's happening
there
great keep it up the what i eat in a
week
you know four days ago you already have
2 000 views or whatever because that's
clearly a hot topic great
keep it up um the answer specific
questions
great keep it up and also
then don't necessarily judge any of your
activities too much in the short term
because the just like the diet soda
thing that you discovered
what's interesting about answering a lot
of different specific questions or
also putting out different variety type
of videos
is that they can break out at day 36
day 48 and day 65
and with 24 uploads a month you're just
you're being radical in a good way to
give yourself a lot of chances
for multiple miracles to happen
six months from now three months from
now six months from now
and continuing to make each one as smart
and strategic as possible
you're also doing shorts and i just did
ten of those were shorts i think i think
i'm gonna kind of
focus my efforts i tried them um
but you know with limited time i'm gonna
focus on the proven
steps versus too much experimentation i
mean
i don't know i think that it could be
interesting
if you go you know hashtag shorts and
keto
i just threw this in here it's
interesting to maybe go
success leaves clues and to somewhat
look around
so okay this person's pretty massive so
you can't base
her views uh she's got she's gonna get
those views just because of her
subscribers
but i actually would affirm maybe it's
not your main strategy but we listed out
like
what i eat you know answer big questions
external traffic facebook groups
i actually think shorts could be
so notice this over on the side here
using vid iq
this guy's getting 615 views an hour
it's 15 seconds what did it just come
out
i don't you did iq must be a few days
ago yeah but uh
and so that was just misreported but
nevertheless you see what i'm doing i'm
just kind of digging around and sort
like what is this one let's see if one
of these is actually accurate
so i wonder if actually okay so vid iqc
shorts as like the total view of the
channel um
you know it's that's so early stage it's
just another
basically another tool in your tool belt
any contractor
that is going to especially a general
contractor that's maybe going to be
building out a house
they they've got their nail gun they've
got their hammer for some specific
things they've got the crowbar
they've got you know multiple different
tools for multiple they've got the drill
or the screw gun and to get things done
and so you're building a youtube empire
i just like i think you're doing it
right
and um and i would still be looking for
those trending topics
trend surfing and influence surfing
which we go did you watch the youtube
hybrid growth blueprint
i did uh tony recommended that to me in
one of his tips to get on that so i
think
the um i mean you talk about it in hyper
growth but
trying to focus on one of the strategies
and i think the one that i
am going to target or in targeting is
skyscraper
okay the term intermittent fasting you
know there you go if i could rank for
intermittent fasting
i mean life-changing
so i think that's the one i'm going to
target i'm going to i'm going to you
know just
intermittent fasting i know what the top
video is it's a tedx talk
the few million views and then a lot
below that it's thomas delaware with two
and a half million subs
but i'm going to try to make that video
better more recent
uh but i'm gonna do that over the next
few months
make a video that tries to well in
and ryan just to affirm that that's
awesome and and great job on you know
even just picking one strategy
following my own advice i'm like there's
all kinds of good ones you're like yeah
you said pick one so
yeah the power focus um you know and you
are going to be a part by the way for
those
that uh are i'm not sure what i'm
talking about this week's
think marketing podcast is on
how to self-publish a book that grows
your channel
and uh i may get pulled into that like
that may be one other one that i add on
there because again just the power of
that
well and and i want to talk to you about
a little bit but for those that
i'm doing a a training with my friend
chandler bolt he's really doing the
training we're just kind of kind of
co-hosting it
on how to go from blank page to publish
author in 90 days
um if you're interested in that it's at
startyourbook.live and you can check out
this
this week's episode of the think
marketing podcast and you can see
that episode but specifically for you
ryan i wanted to go deep
and um just affirm that and say
check it out this may or may not be the
right time to do it you got to audit
your own bandwidth in your own time
however i would affirm i would go all in
and do it
no matter what and here's exactly my
thinking if i'm you
it's to position yourself in
intermittent fasting and
in your journey and being in authority
having the published book
is huge but you also said something
related to
uh skyscraper method and that was that
the top video was a tedx talk
so what this becomes is it becomes
actually thinking
when you want to be a thought expert
just like you are
and want to build your youtube empire is
maybe this extension
of a personal brand and planting your
flag in a particular topic
you then also when you write a book you
create what my friend rory teaches
which you can teach a chapter that's 17
minutes
you could teach the whole book that's in
the book or the audiobook
you could teach a one or two hour class
that's like section one of the book
and then you also could teach a two-day
workshop and that's actually maybe the
entirety of the book if you were to
teach it in person
and you create kind of this accordion of
elasticity and authority
but it actually could oh we lost him it
could map back
to ultimately uh building
out a ted talk which actually could be a
tedx talk
which could be the pinnacle of ranking a
video and becoming the thought leader on
a topic so anyways
just a thought for ryan that i wanted
him to hear you can watch the replay of
this
but something to think about in regards
to one of the powerful reasons of and if
you want to learn more about that
check out this week's episode of the
think marketing podcast on how to
self-publish a book that grows
your channel and makes you money and it
actually ends up helping you make better
youtube content
and you can use sometimes the youtube
videos you've already made to actually
be the chapters of the book there's a
lot of interesting things
maybe it's different than how you would
normally think in terms of building your
youtube empire
but definitely check that out
okay we're gonna try to get to as many
more as we can but we're coming up at 5
00 p.m pacific time
i wanted to connect with gear junk news
35 again here
your junkie it looks like there's no
echo how's it going
good sean how are you i'm doing great
thanks for coming out real quick i just
no problem um i catch
i try to catch as much of your stuff as
i can i work from home so
fortunately i've had a chance to binge a
lot of your stuff recently
uh on behalf of all small youtubers
everywhere thank you for
you and your staff for all the
contributions my goodness
what a resource uh anyway thank you my
question in a nutshell
is i would like to start a gear
another gear review channel of which
there are a billion however
uh this is guitar pedal reviews with a
twist do you remember the pick a path
adventure books we're about the same age
i'm sure you do
dude choose your own adventure that's
like the fuel of my childhood
right now imagine now most guitar
players don't just have one pedal
they've got
10 or 20 or 30 or 50. this is going to
be like
pick a path adventures but a community
pedal board
the viewers get to decide what other
pedals
are on the merry-go-round of what's on
the board today
of course there's going to be a specific
pedal that's being reviewed as the
highlight
but it's a community pedal board where
it's displayed with other pedals and
reviewed with other pedals
should i start out in my own unique
format or go
all in um start out with the the typical
review format
and incorporate my own style from there
um i like the creativity but i
also um like ideas to start as simple as
possible so what i would do
is i would view that as a potential show
or
series on a much simpler channel no
matter how much competition
there is i think that gear heads gear
[ __ ]
uh guitar pedals um there's just
you know uh culture
musician culture if you just put out a
lot of consistent content
you cover a lot of different pedals like
i guess
my default is the tried and true like if
you could just make
great comparison videos versus videos
just
this pedal versus this like there's
unlimited versus camera videos
people have kind of done them but
sometimes they haven't done them well
and they're still people want
but what about the m6 mark ii versus the
a6400 but what about the zv1 versus the
so we don't even get to enough of them
and yet people want specific videos
about specific questions
so the versus videos the specific
product review
yes i'm sure a majority of the pedals
and the mainstream pedals
have been covered at length and maybe
it's hard to break in but i also know
that even the most popular pedals are
kind of like the canon m50
and the canon m50 has a 10 zillion
videos about it and people still get
views because there's such a large
market for it
alternatively there are people that
because i know when my friend miguel
and one of our vra students was he was
uh doing
a a channel and he would just cover some
kind of a niche
channel or a niche pedal or something
you know specific about it and the views
weren't very
incredible at first but as he did it
over time whoa that video has
7 600 views and a lot of people clicked
on the affiliate link
so to summarize i would actually
probably just make
basically a gear channel and even maybe
more niche like guitars or maybe guitar
pedals
i would give yourself i prefer making
channels that are a big enough brand
that would allow me to maybe do
all things electric guitars and even if
the videos for a year
or forever are just about guitar pedals
here's what i mean
it might just be gear junk like you know
it's called gear junkie but all the
videos are about pedals
i wouldn't probably name a channel
guitar pedals
junkie because it's the brand doesn't
need to be that much
but the videos can be matched and then
what i would do
is i would experiment under the umbrella
of gear junkie youtube channel with
what you just said i still like the idea
but what you might find
is it's hard for people to understand it
it's not popular
it does they don't really get that
engaged with it or
you just cracked open the most
a whole movement and five years from now
you're on stage at namm
the national association of music
merchants
and and they're like tell us you know
you created a whole thing with this
choose your own adventure
petals thing your youtube channel is a
million subscribers this is true
like i mean who knows like that a very
innovative idea could grow into that
but i suppose with the moonshot strategy
that's kind of like a creative like moon
shot
i also like to be anchored in total
practicality and you can play both games
under that umbrella
give that friday show of choose your own
adventure
four weeks eight weeks try it for a
quarter
give it give it a friday show for for uh
three months
one upload a month that's 12 uploads and
then be like
huh i don't know people aren't really
getting it i don't really like doing it
anymore they might like it you might not
like it
i think that a lot of us and i want
everyone in the community kind of hear
this
that there's definitely like almost the
practical
path we should all stick with and then
we should have a little bit of our
bandwidth for create
creative ideas and experimentation
that's the r d department that's
that's research and development and
maybe something genius comes out of
there and comes into our day-to-day
practical schedule
so that's kind of how i'd approach it is
that uh smart thinking what do you think
i agree i i would like to establish
myself first before i go too far into
the deep end of what
you know what you're referring to is you
know the bigger concept which i agree
it's a bit much in the in the guitar
pedal review format you've got you know
you've got the gopro at the end of the
neck
pointed at the guitar you can't see the
face and then you've got a secondary
static camera on the pedal and you can
see you know the effect of the tone as
they tweak the knobs
i'd like to start out as something a
little bit more personality and then
as the reviews progress as you're saying
put out the content
you know like you're always saying punch
fear in the face and that's my big
problem
is i've been watching you for a couple
months and i still have
four count them four videos um
none up to what i would consider my
level of what i would like to put out
but again that's also punch
perfectionism in the face so it's a
one-two punch
working at it um i agree i i would like
to start
out with you know the the traditional
format and then
a little flavor here a little flavor
there and the next thing you know you're
hooked on wow
you know it's not just he doesn't just
review one pedal he puts three
overdrives after it two reverbs in front
of it
who does that you know kind of one of
those deals it's like it's
it's a wacky review you don't know what
he's going to throw at this thing next
real guitar players don't just play one
pedal
the canon m50 would be equivalent to the
ibanez
tube screamer it is probably the most
famous guitar pedal
of all time it's been cloned um you know
numerous numerous times everybody loves
a tube screamer but what happens if we
put
a tube screamer in front of this
everybody's favorite pedal
you just introduce impact you just
unpacked a
strategy that our think community
definitely needs to hear
popular item plus
new spin because you said everybody
knows
about the ibanez tube screamer and so if
you throw in a
crispy thumbnail and then you put a spin
on it so that's like
you know canon m50 with sony lenses
like i don't even know why you'd want to
do that but it's like
because it's like some weird spin to it
some weird hack to it
known super popular thing potentially
product a good theme for today's coffee
with channel
plus unique modern spin and you're
saying that's
that's a great strategy to unpack
because sometimes we go too obscure and
people are like well i don't even know
what the thing is
but if you can anchor on what people do
know and bridge it to something fresh
and
new unique that could be a really
powerful video idea
thank you thank you um i like to
incorporate slow and
try not to get overwhelmed with the
enormity of what i would like to do as
well as
just have fun with it because after all
if you can't have fun with it
it's obvious the viewers know you're not
having fun they're not going to have fun
they don't want to see somebody who's
doing something fake
for the sake of doing it yeah so true
the passion has to come through
let me just encourage you with one thing
you know great job putting up four
videos
i know that you're at this place of uh
you know still needing to punch fear in
the face
and press record but one thing that
um i've noticed a couple places we got a
message recently
i saw it from actually a creator who you
would never think this person struggled
with confidence or struggled with
putting themselves out there
and they were being interviewed and they
said you know this idea has been in my
head
for five years but i didn't press record
and we just got a message that was
emailed to us and they said listen i've
been watching i've been learning i've
been studying but i haven't pressed
record for five
years what a lot of people don't know is
that
i started yes i was putting some videos
out there
but i was afraid to really lean into
taking youtube serious i almost was like
like treating it like i've kind of just
dabbled there's kind of a hobby
like it's it's my side thing i didn't
really want to put my heart my emotions
maybe because of fear of failing fear of
telling people i was serious
fear of who even knows what or just even
wanting to you know convince myself for
being my own head about whatever
and it was really for years
i mean maybe 2010 to really 2015 when
this whole think media thing
really and when i started to do video
influencers eventually with benji
because of years of kind of playing it
behind the scenes or playing
like i almost had a guard up and the
reason i just say that is is just to
encourage you that
and everyone listening because you bring
that up like if you're listening to this
and you've been like man i don't know i
don't i've been watching your stuff for
three months and i haven't pressed
record yet
you're in good company like sometimes we
learn and absorb
for six months for nine months for a
year i don't want that to be excuse
i want you to post your first video
today but at the same time
even when it came to started building my
online business i went to events i
bought
courses i strategized i dreamed i wrote
google docs about things and i didn't
really create anything even for years
but i was in the research and
development phase you don't want to get
stuck
in analysis paralysis you don't want to
overthink
things you don't want procrastination to
last forever
but sometimes the seeds of your dreams
and the seeds of your greatness need
need time to gestate while being hidden
and being watered before they spring up
and they begin to be visible and seen
i think that might be something i just
kind of wanted our whole community to
hear
but just to encourage you i mean you've
posted the four videos but
like you know you're formulating these
things sometimes it takes a process
of of of dreaming a little bit but then
you gotta just take action
when are you posting your next video and
do you feel ready to go all in
it's a daily is you know i sit over for
10 hours from
my computer and you know among others
you know
in the background in my ear and you know
a million ideas
come six o'clock uh spend our time
okay family time then it's 8 30 and it's
bedtime it's
bedtime in an hour you know so it's you
know good afternoon
for everything i'll take 20 minutes do
everything set and then
hit record and try to do your best but
at the end of the day those
are all excuses um that's what weekends
are for right
yeah tell you what check your
35 on uh sometime
next week i should have something filmed
this weekend i've actually got two
things i'm gonna do in a small batch
recording on and uh if you have any
comments or suggestions
let me know i'm gonna do it this week
and i'm
tired of being a watcher time to create
all right you're poaching your video
this weekend the audio is kind of
sketching out right now but i caught
most of that
and uh and i want to thank you so much
for coming on i appreciate you
and uh by next week we're seeing that
next video
yes my friend john thank you for
everything
cheers um okay friends
couple questions uh someone asked if
we're so hiring we are
www.work with
we're also going to be updating it and
we're flipping it a little bit we're
going to be hiring some different
positions i posted that in the chat
um we're going to do one more we have
matt coming on
and uh i want to answer your questions
though as well or just a couple things
that i saw
smash like if you are getting value so
far thanks for being here appreciate you
and um today's episode is brought to you
by
uh think masterclass dot com
i just recorded a brand new free web
class one hour class
available through the weekend on the
replay think master link in the
description down below
if you've heard that link before and
you're like it sounds like you talk
about a lot we update it all the time
like the page that it leads to because
here's a tip we go to godaddy or
wherever you buy urls we buy a url and
we just redirect it
so it allows me to verbally say think
masterclass.com and i can send that to
any page we use a software called
kajabi if you're ever curious think
media tools and that's where we build
out
pages and host like our courses and host
all kinds of different things
and so that's what that is and so
there's always we do updates to it we've
changed the content of the class we've
updated things
sometimes it's actually you can watch it
all the time and it's a different
version right now it's a live class and
the replay is up for a few days and i
want you to see it
because at the beginning of this video
definitely watch the replay if you're
just joining
i shared three different video ideas
different angles on product reviews
and really we just learned from gear
junkie
that uh another idea that's super smart
is to take the most popular
product in your niche and
combine it or do a unique spin to it
even if it's been out for a while like
the canon m50
in cameras and youtube cameras and tech
think about a unique spin
you could do or a unique combo you could
do with it
that's an idea and so definitely
register for the class where you can
watch the replay think masterclass.com
and smash like if you've been getting
value
so far and definitely check out the
replay
and um matt my man good to see you
remind everybody about your channel and
about what you're up to
and i'm excited we've been able to
finally connect again
definitely so my name my child's name is
metal eagle
chester so i'm basically um authority of
teaching chess
for beginners amateurs and all the way
up
and i really like to just create
educational content for people learning
chess
i love it and i remember we've talked
about your channel in the past i gave
you a challenge how have things been
going
very good so i've been i now published
34 videos
and i'm thinking i'm optimistic for um
this near future
i'm publishing all these videos uh what
do you say
what have you learned from publishing 34
videos so we were talking about
getting to that 30 mark and now you're
there
814 views which is awesome 11 in the
last month
12 new subscribers so you're seeing
growth you're seeing forward motion
what have you been learning i've been
learning about experiments
with all sorts of topics and we'll see
what's um what's more um
grabbing to the audience it was not and
i'm just seeing
what is like my direction so i
was trying to also just look at the the
days of the weeks and times i should
post but i don't have enough analytics
to say that oh
i have to need to post the specific time
or day
that people the audience want to go but
um
one thing is like a it's like a
consistency the question is
for like being consistent um for example
if i
post two videos a week and i get sick
and i can only
post one video a week does that youtube
punish me before
not being consistent in that sense or
not good question
no not at all you know um
uh youtube verifiably they have said
they will not punish your channel if you
stop uploading
now there could be ramifications from
stop up
when you stop uploading meaning not only
do you feel like things slow down
but they might dramatically slow down
and here's why when you post a new video
it potentially gets not just
the subscribers or if it gets suggested
and people discover it
but any new video is always a chance to
activate the rest of your library
i definitely understand that what we're
doing at think media now is crazy
because we have multiple content
creators
you know i started as you know just
shooting videos in my bedroom by myself
and scaled things to where we gathered
the think avengers and we have omar and
nolan and tony and heather and mel and
they're
and we're posting content and we're
posting five days a week about to be
seven days a week on think media because
we're gonna do two shorts a week
and five uploads a week here's the thing
that's crazy about that strategy not
just that many videos
but also any one of those videos if it
breaks out
activates the rest of the videos in our
library and it's just this crazy
snowball
now definitely not recommended because
again someone's like oh i should just
post five a week
it's good stuff to do five quality
videos a week depending on your format
um again we have multiple people that
are helping with it
um but to to that point you should never
feel because youtube could drive you
kind of to burn out if you're like i
can't take a week off you can totally
take a week off
and it's not going to affect you
negatively youtube doesn't penalize you
or like
we're going to make you have to work
twice as hard when you post another
video
none of that will necessarily happen but
you may see
kind of just your overall analytics dip
a little bit because your new
the new posts are not activating or
reminding people to watch the rest of
the videos in your library
um definitely so basically i got the
for the first start when i saw you first
in january you had a very good
very good goal to for me to reach so
from here so i have a really good uh 139
subscriber
really solid account i think for two
months uh
for posting videos i started february um
uh what do you think i should do like
now is the focus going forward
yeah so just to recap and this has been
cool to see like a coffee with kennel
journey and so matt two months in
139 subscribers um
2529 views and posted a little over 30
videos
so the challenge that i gave matt back
when
he jumped on coffee kennel i don't
remember how many videos you had then
uh zero okay so yeah so yeah it's zero
so i was like well here's problem number
one
the secret to getting views on youtube
is posting videos
on youtube and so i was like don't even
don't even worry about the results post
30 videos
so this i love this story matt i'm so
glad you're on here because
you know again there's people watching
this we're on the sidelines we're
worried
about starting you got to just start and
then you don't just post one video and
then sit around and be like oh man it's
not doing that well
you got to post like 30 videos to get
some data to get some momentum
and think about this i'm sure there
might be a little bit of overlap but
2529
humans have watched matt's videos now
and he's only two months in he's just
getting started some
people on youtube experience quick
breakout success
but it is i think crazy that we would
have the audacity
that actually we would even get results
on our content in a year's time
like you're already getting results in
like affirmation that 139 people have
clicked subscribe
but like even like my
mentality that i want you to have but
it's more speaking just to the think
community
i want you to have your head down grind
on
post in that averages at 15 a month
right that matt got out there and and
you follow that up with 12 months of
consistent hustle
now making some strategic tweaks can
help you get even more results but if we
just follow the math right here
you've been doing this two months yep
but people go how do i get how do i get
a thousand subscribers
you know like every like well well dude
139
times times two over the next 10 months
that'd be five it took two months to get
139
so in
is that right you have you have 700 subs
in the next why did i times it by five
let's and
uh okay here we go so let's let me redo
the math 139
divided by 2 69 times 12.
let's do that so over the next year
you're gonna have 834 subs if you stay
at the same rate
i pretty much can guarantee you that
you'll probably have a thousand twelve
hundred or two thousand
because it's not a linear growth curve
on youtube
some of your past videos aka
your uh videos that are
two months ago that have 280 views or
this one that has
671 views or whatever punchline
is that you might hit a thousand subs in
six months you might hit a thousand subs
or two thousand in a year just to answer
the question how do i get a thousand sub
subs grind
put out videos post smart videos and
now let's get into the strategies so
that's just kind of like the raw raw
put your head down keep doing the grit i
want everyone to see the hustle you're
putting in
the next thing is now that you've posted
30 videos we can have this conversation
success leaves clues and to me
this 10 chess concepts that every chess
player should master
i'm wondering when are you gonna do part
two of this um
maybe you can do it as soon as possible
so this is actually the first video i
ever posted my channel so apparently
it's
popping off so exactly when you have a
chance to say okay
some of my new videos get 18 views or
on like a 30 you know they like
what's the one that's like this like try
three chess concepts every chess player
should master
try try a hundred
you know like like i'm not kidding
literally
i think about um the chance of doing
like the top three tips a video that's
about the top 10 tips
and then the top 50 tips includes the
three and the ten of course
but it's like it's like an hour long and
you'd be surprised the watch time
somebody might sit down and be like okay
this is like a master like this is
school
this is me like in chess like really
getting and
and you give people a different
opportunity so that that's video format
one
i would do like one of those a week at
least i'd do like
three and then i would i would deal with
alternate titles and variations of
titles
and then why do you think this video did
so good uh
it's basically it's like a a lot of
people would just want to get started
with chess especially with the
what you talked about before the queen's
gambit craze that happened last year
people want to know what they want to
focus on chess to get
like decent on it so it basically got
really popular i shared it on facebook i
shared it with my friends and
it's very popular super smart so i would
try to
redo what you learned there as well
right like
uh and so these top two ones i think are
super interesting
and then are you spending some time
looking at like what others are doing
like looking at st
louis chess club or gotham chess to see
if there's any video ideas that you
could kind of spin off of
yeah so that's that's the thing so um
i know that the i heard a lot of times
like um you prefer that no text be in
the thumbnail
but i see a lot of chess successfully
screws
but a lot of really prominent chess um
channels
they have a bunch of text maybe too much
for the vri
okay i mean you got to experiment and
and it's going to be about the content
as well but yeah try that success leaves
clues
yeah why don't you have any videos that
start with chess openings for beginners
why haven't you made that video
oh um yeah that's a good
idea yeah that would be because
what i looked i looked over on the right
suggested videos because it made me
think
just so you understood how i kind of got
to that first of all i think making
everybody listening your topic for
beginners is just a super smart video to
make
but what i did was i clicked on this
then i realized okay what's youtube
recommending me
so then i started like looking over here
how about this how about a one hour
beginner chess lesson
oh okay with uh metal eager uh
eagle metal eagle yeah and then and then
i looked over here
i mean how about six checkmate patterns
you know three checkmate patterns you
should know
but then i s 10 chess tactics but i saw
beginner openings
and i just thought openings chess
openings the king's gambit
um and obviously you know this one is 12
years old
and it's a classic with 2.5 million
views but if you can do a new spin
on um just some of those basic videos so
for a learning point matt you did you
did put out 30 videos
i would argue some of your titles they
weren't the videos that you should make
they're fine that you did make them
okay but like for those listening when i
say post your first 30 videos
matt did a i'm blown away like it's you
did incredible you took action
you started messy you punch fear in the
face you just post the videos and you're
getting some results
i think though your results would be
crazy better if
your 30 videos were number one
beginner chest openings number two uh
you know three checkmate patterns you
must know
number three and in literally
number number three one hour beginner
chess lesson with meadow eagle
eagle number four uh three pawn end game
moves you need to know number you know
what i mean like meaning
you're making the best and the right
video ideas
doesn't necessarily mean because
obviously the content's got to be good
and the thumbnail and the click-through
rate and whatnot
but you want to give your top 30 videos
the best chance of success
like i would argue that um
that this was like this was definitely
this was a good uh
test and maybe work you know about
someone
like first metal eagle swiss on
lichnist.org like i just don't even that
doesn't seem super like this is great
this video might do really well by the
way great thumbnail
10 tactics and chess combinations and
great title
like this one seems a little bit lower
quality to me is that fair
yeah yeah it's kind of vague or a little
more niche
so like what the 30 videos
are is all is my point so you're off to
a crazy start
the next steps are this your next 30
videos
tweaking now though remaking and
updating
some of your best ones specifically you
know the
uh top one which was you know
four three chess cam concepts you should
know
studying some of the beginner openings
whatever videos making some of those
and then finally i want you to
experiment with like a long form video
you have well you have one that says
chess symbol with q a
i don't mean that i literally mean
editing together
like a super video we call them content
marathons
[Applause]
and i evan carmichael does it like this
right you have
garyvee's top 10 rules okay
so it's that idea but what mo but some
people maybe haven't realized and that's
like 15 minutes
is that there's like garyvee top 50. so
then there's like
115 minutes okay i don't know if he has
he done like a top 100 yet
like then there's okay well
this is this is different so maybe not
top 100 but but literally
50 rules and the videos are like two
hours long
so i guess what i'm saying is i actually
mark my words like if you can put
together
a couple this is how you do the content
marathons you do like
your chess whatever i already forgot but
whatever it's called
tactics you need to know just concepts
and i don't even know if there are a
hundred cons i mean i'm sure there
probably
is a lot so it'd just be interest it'd
be an interesting test
and so i mean literally it's like number
one and you're like going through and
it's like just a
super long thorough video and maybe you
don't go from 10 to 100
but i think it'd be super interesting
the way basically evan carmichael's
doing it is he does
10 gary v top 10 rules and then he
combines them into garyvee's top 50
rules so he's also reusing the content
and restructuring it you know
strategically and everything but
uh then you go well nobody wants to
watch that hour and a half video except
for the people who do and then the watch
time hack
is insane oh yeah
definitely so uh thank you for the
um the goals and also with the
um the impressions that you get from my
channel and the one thing i just learned
from
watching youtube video like crazy is
that a lot of people
said oh if i were to start over again i
really like to experiment with the first
videos
so i try to do that with the first 30
videos it's uh
talk about various topics and see what
sticks
and uh that's why um there's probably
videos are not
performing a while but you told me um
the first two examples
yeah you told me that the first of the
third videos would be the worst ones
right that's right and so and so i mean
you knocked it out of the park
i think now it's like layering on the
next strategy to like okay let's tweak
in the next 30.
and i actually think you know a lot of
people have this goal of getting to a
thousand subscribers
i think you're going to get to a
thousand subscribers in six
months or less on the other side of
continuing
this is the process of youtube it's like
make a plan
execute the plan and then you got to
evaluate right it's what we teach
in vra it's the review r and actually
you kind of gotta skip the review until
you actually have something to review
you can always review one video but now
you're in an even better place re redo
your strategy come on chess
you know redo like consider like your
strategy for youtube for the next month
and then review it again and it's repeat
and that's why vra's a system as you
know
it just keeps refining and refining and
refining and refining the process
and building that momentum up to build
your youtube empire has today been
helpful matt
definitely definitely it's uh priceless
for me thank you awesome
well i appreciate you so much grateful
you're part of our community and
uh thanks for coming on thank you
all right uh let me
text my wife and we're gonna do one more
here
uh i probably gotta go in like 15
minutes here
uh
and you know happy wife happy life smack
like
for the wife card what the wife texts
the communication good communication
hey today's uh brought to you if you
want to learn a little bit more about
um our proprietary process that we bit
built for growing youtube channels
hasn't just worked for me has worked for
like hundreds of uh
uh students that have gotten like silver
play buttons or full time
and then thousands of people are getting
momentum growth
a couple hundred bucks a month couple
thousand bucks a month just a lot of
different crazy results
it starts with just checking out our
free class we'll tell you a little bit
about things
um and worth your time in and of itself
if you're liking this kind of content
and then uh and then there's you know
opportunities to go deeper with us or
not if you're like nah i'm just down to
kind of hang out here on youtube or
watch some of your free stuff cool too
pretty um
relax i'm gonna flex this a little bit i
got the hashtag good husband i gotta
flex
that and uh appreciate that matthew says
review super i mean matthew recently
went full time um uh he's been with vra
for a while and
uh i think we've got an episode you
should check out matthew's story here on
the think marketing channel
you'll love that kind of stuff and uh
all right we're gonna keep it going
and so here we go we got troy on the
show
troy how's it going good man i
appreciate you squeezing me in at the
end
yeah for sure tell me about your uh
channel and what is your question post
your channel
private chat if it's hard to find uh
yeah it's uh troy blyton
personalized name cool how can i help
yeah so
so i started uh well first of all thank
you for
everything you do because you know
watching your videos has really
catapulted me into you know gaining over
a thousand subscribers in like
two months you know so that's really
good and um
yeah just paying attention to all the
tips you guys give so the question that
i do have is that
so clearly my you know it says uh locks
is basically dreadlocks is like
what i talk about mostly i do like
interviews i have a show called
dreadlock talk which is like podcast
and um you know i kind of want to start
implementing my other interests into my
videos
and i don't want to just stick myself in
that box of just my hair
so um i kind of want to just you know
you to check my channel out and see
what you thought about that and ways i
could do that because i don't want to
just abandon my
my subscribers and just completely go
left field
because um but but you know my hair is a
part of my journey so
that's something i want to continue to
make videos about but not strictly hair
so yeah yeah yeah so what do you what do
you want to happen like what's the big
vision
if if 12 months from now uh
you reached your ideal
destination with what your youtube
channel is doing with maybe
where you're working how you're spending
your time where money is coming from
what is your ideal end result
well ideally i want to be a full-time
content creator
and i want to have i want to be able to
um
you know have products that i sell
through
and i can use my my content as a way to
you know have my followers or you know
supporters
get to that those products whether it be
merch or
uh ebooks anything like that so
that's mine are those about do you want
to sell
physical products related to like hair
dreads
do you want to sell what's the ebook
about what's the merch
the ebook that i'm working on is
actually about you know how to um
how to start getting free form dreads
because the the type of dreads that i
have
it's a whole community on youtube it's
basically people that just naturally let
their hair lock up and
you don't go to the salon and get them
done you just you know it's a full
journey of just you know keeping your
hair clean and it locks up over time
so that's the niche that i'm in and um
you know i think that's really why my
channel grew as fast as it did because
it's such a
niche topic and um so merch wise
to you know here and stuff or like a
broad thing like the ideas i have is
like you know
motivational
yeah so merchandise it doesn't
necessarily have to be about hair but
like the ideas i have are more so like
motivational quotes and
just designs i have and um the e-book is
actually about hair though
it's uh like i mentioned before it's
about you know how to
you know the thing the things kind of i
talk about in my videos but more in like
a compact
uh form okay so
have you found is there any successful
books out there uh
that you can that that would be similar
to that like what would the
the book category be called like how to
style or how
like give me a keyword phrase it would
basically be like a guide to
to freeform locks that's that's
essentially what
what it would what my idea is and i
don't know
one of his people took about this topic
on youtube she has an ebook i don't know
how successful it was
um she still sells it on amazon but
yeah what's interesting it's like is
like definitely the
the the the uh products and actually
like
the the faux hair itself
is crazy especially for right all these
yeah like yes that's a little bit
different though you know that's that's
more so like
extension hair and like my niche is
literally just like
you know just growing your hair
naturally and just letting it
form on its own 100 i guess i guess one
of the smart things to do like we're
kind of a ground floor of like i'm just
working backwards from 12
uh months from now i would think market
research
i think the ebook and and you know is a
great thing we actually have
i think it'll be super helpful if you
want to check out uh this
uh i think this week's think marketing i
watched you yesterday come on man okay
cool it was a pretty helpful year
was it was did you leave me sure for
sure i loved like the whole
self-publishing aspect of it and like
all those type of things so that's
actually something i've been i've been
i've been into for the past month or two
so because that would be a lot of videos
about that
i would be like i would just be thinking
about how to
um like if you build influence
a lot of like famous youtube influencers
like real famous like they could write a
book about anything
and they have enough people that love
them but i also wonder
about i'm just kind of trying to think
about the right positioning um
and even the right waist honest i think
the merch thing could really work i
think a lot of i think accessories i
mean i would imagine is there some stuff
where you
will you throw different like
accessories so i mean you got like you
got a thing right now
i got this this is just like a regular
like hair tie from walmart uh i thought
oh how how i would go with that but uh
that's why yeah man i don't know
that but that's and i did a little bit
of that the internet's going a little
sketchy we're talking about it
uh i was just saying that i didn't i
don't really know anything else about uh
accessories-wise i mean there's like
beads and stuff i mean maybe i could
look into that
but i don't personally well i mean i
mean step one
of kind of making a plan is kind of make
a strategy while you're taking action so
you're already doing that but in the
meantime i'd be thinking about okay
am i is it the merge and that's that's
the idea of i'm gonna reverse engineer
back from full-time content creator
what am i good at what's the business
model what's the monetization plan
that's one category back really to your
question
is i mean you're doing a ton of things
right you got the growth you're tapping
into a niche
there's people loving it there's people
connecting with you
um there's growth happening on the
channel
uh i don't why haven't you posted in the
last couple weeks
so i've been heavy on tick tock lately
and i've gotten over 11
000 followers in like two weeks so
yeah so i've been on that but my next
video is scheduled to post tomorrow
and are you juggling a day job right now
currently
uh just uber right i actually i play for
the harlem globetrotters and um
you know we're we're heading back on
tour and and around well we're training
campus july so
we just got that call today so uber
harlem globetrotters and then building
up that social
you know yeah i mean um
to me i think kind of some final
thoughts
the channel is your personal brand name
and i think you want to stay
true and ride the momentum of what's
working for you
but i would experiment and
um meaning i would i would i
you said i want to put a little bit more
of my stuff i mean i think
um i think where a lot of times i would
recommend people do
a niche channel and it's like this is a
channel about locks it's a channel about
dreads
in my opinion it's not i think in your
case in getting to talk to you
it's a channel about you and that's a
large part of what you're doing i would
also maybe say
80 of your content like seven out of or
eight out of 10 uploads
maybe six out of 10 uploads stay tried
and true to what's helping you kind of
grow but then you sort of experiment
with two to four uploads
and you maybe tie them all together
because
even just from talking you've seen the
thumbnails i i see the opportunity for
you to be a proper influencer tick
tock's going well
entertainment tying into this kind of
iconic
look and brand that you have as well but
also
um just going for the pure
uh creative idea aspect of it like i
mean do you
do you incorporate like humor or
anything into it any kind of story for
sure
in my editing style you know that's yeah
and what are
what are the other ideas that you want
to experiment with that you feel like
you can't
so so i'm really into calisthenics i do
all body weight workouts so
i want to i put that a little bit of
that in my last video i might want to do
like
yeah maybe this guy that i interviewed
i do enemy interviews and a guy that i
interviewed he actually has a fitness
channel and we linked up and we did a
video for his channel
so that was cool um so yeah just stuff
like that and
you know what i eat in a day videos
people have been asking for because i'm
into health like that
so yeah man yes me when people go wait a
minute
sean you always talk about niche down
why does troy get to i go well
because the common denominator is you i
mean because you're the niche i mean
that's the
that's sort of like if people are
interested in you and there's got to be
self-awareness for a lot of us to think
we can always try that but sometimes
that can fall apart
i think uh on the other hand if you have
self-awareness of
of of the personality of the vibe and if
people are interested and if it's
working then you gotta ride that
um i think the biggest thing is to
to just analyze you're listening you're
already listening listen to your
community
listen to the comments don't just listen
to the comments listen to the data
like the likes and dislikes you don't
want to take them personally
they're not an attack on you they're
attack they're not an attack their
feedback on the topic
even a dislike we're like ah someone
should be able to say like
i disliked it i subscribed for something
else just listen like listen to the
analytics
listen to the feedback experiment with
videos
and what i could see is i could see i
like to think organization wise
i could see you having do you did you
name your podcast
or your talk your interview yeah
dreadlock talk
i could see that becoming you know what
i mean like that's it could be about
like
just interesting people like you have
you eventually could have like really
famous people whatever just because like
big names they could talk about
and you might it might not i maybe it's
always someone with dreadlocks right
that's on there
mm-hmm yeah i could see or someone that
had them yeah
you're you're you got the dreads like
like dreadlock talk is you and so
i could just see like dreadlock talk is
because like your vibe your energy
your uh ethos about life your thing and
dreadlock talk comes out
every um you know monday and your guest
this week is kevin hart
you know so like and then like your
guest this week
is uh you know joe biden like i don't
know you know what i mean
like if you really played out like joe
rogan has all kinds of different people
joe the ufc fighter the
you know you get it like is is uh
the comedian is the kind of common
factor
interesting conversations with all kinds
of different people and i do think
so to me i could see it going that way i
could see
that's like if i thought buckets that's
monday
i could see vlogs or like i think it
gets the fitness thing
actually fits the less in my mind
it's not that you can't do it but if
people want to actually follow along and
learn fitness from you the reason they
click subscribe
is for those workouts
right mm-hmm yeah so
but if it's kind of like if you have you
said lifestyle
if like you're doing some stuff that's
maybe inspiring or encouraging some
people what you're working on like
i'm leaving that up to you that's
experimentation and then certainly like
even the videos you're doing uh i hope
that that leads you with some
some clarity and just some ideas but i
basically would just lean in
and it's like i think when you think
about what videos you should make
a huge way to answer this question i
want our whole community to hear this
is you just need to really understand
who you're talking to
like to the degree that you understand
what's weird is if
if someone could if someone has a
youtube channel that is directed for my
personality type
they would realize that if they had gary
vaynerchuk on the show i would click on
it
they would realize that if they talked
if they made a video that
was like five business lessons we can
learn from the wu-tang clan i would
click
on it and they would learn that if it
was like
five bio hacks like five quick workouts
and five supplements that'll give you
twice the energy i would click on that
and if an influencer realized they were
attracting entrepreneurial
biohacking obsessed millennials
who like macklemore says wu-tang raised
you and i grew up in
skateboarding and snowboard culture then
they
they would just you kind of know who
you're talking to so in that regards
it might seem like there's no cohesion
and
and common theme amongst the niche but
there actually is because the niche is
who you're talking to
it's a particular type of person so can
you experiment with the fitness
you can do whatever you want it's your
channel uh you know you've done a ton of
stuff related to locks
and you could double down on that but
you also could just experiment with
what are the conversations maybe it's
not just conversations about locks
but it's interesting conversations with
characters
in your bigger community whether they
have lobster they ever did or not
because dreadlock talk is is about
the topics that matter to people who
think like you do
or people who are exploring or or want
to
iron out ideas and have conversations
in your space when you know who you're
talking to on youtube the creator who
understands the viewer best
wins yeah i heard i heard daryl say that
oh yeah yeah for sure we said that in
our strategy workshop at the beginning
of the year i bet daryl stole my stuff
no i'm just kidding youtube youtube
formula has been a killer book did you
check that out from daryl i didn't get
it but uh it's it's definitely in my
cart on amazon for sure
nice um absolutely man i really
appreciate
it and i don't want to get you in
trouble with your wife but i have one
analytics question it should be really
quick
um so i had a youtube a youtube
short and um it had copyrighted music so
and it had like almost 2 000 views but
then i saw this
uh this post on instagram where they
were talking about you know don't have
copyrin
don't get a copyright claim on your
youtube channel if you want to get
monetized
and i impulsely i just deleted it and it
screwed up my analytics like i can't see
my watch hours now
so it does do you know how long that
takes to adjust back to normal
wait you can't see any watch hour or you
just it just shows me like
it went down for something like i can't
fight over watch hours
say it again we lost the internet i i
can't sorry i can't see my overall watch
hours like my total watch hours are just
gone now
it shows me like reese like past couple
days or something
it's weird yeah i mean yeah i i wish i
could give you a better answer
than like sometimes glitches happen
sometimes i've seen i got zero views in
a day
like it's because the analytics broke
like it went from we get like 115 000 to
like 150 a day and it was zero
obviously it wasn't zero unless i was
like oh crap what happened youtube bro
but they they fill back in so sometimes
uh you have to just give the youtube
studio uh
a chance to work things out i imagine
that will correct
itself in a few days and it might take a
week or two
all right cool sean i really appreciate
it man
appreciate you troy thanks so much for
coming on and uh being a part of the
community
absolutely god bless god bless
coffee with kennel y'all smash the like
button if you're
uh grateful for life and uh thanks so
much for
uh being a part of the show today i'm
headed to costco
come on um the pandemic
is shifting because i heard this
some costcos you can get samples now
yeah minimal samples but my friend jeff
was like there was there were samples
at costco it could be that we are
turning a corner
like if there's one symbol of hope on
the horizon
it's when costco starts offering samples
again
when cost goes at full speed if you
don't know the sample strategies you got
to realize
you don't need to get lunch you need to
show up to costco hungry
because you can leave costco full just
from
samples and anybody know any costco
people
amarita is like thanks for the tip sean
or that were you thanking me for my
costco tips i'm just kidding
i appreciate it matthew appreciates you
life is good
uh ella trader joe's coffee samples are
coming oh coming back
soon come on the
the a new day is dawning and uh super
grateful
uh we've got mel helping me in the chat
or tony
if you haven't watched the master class
the replay's up for a couple days
thinkmasterclass.com i just recorded
that last night some really cool stuff
lol costco sample dinner here i come i
heard from jeff that it's not the full
sample dinner yet he's like it was kind
of like
reduced duty you know what i mean or
whatever he was like it was they were
there
it wasn't the costco we knew from the
glorious past it was
it was uh it was the half
it was the 50 capacity 75 capacity oh
are we back to 100
capacity we're going through layers of
uh reopening i suppose
and so um amarita
uh yes been there to costco too but i
meant the youtube tips appreciate you
hey
check out some links in the description
down below if you want to connect or you
have any questions
we can always hook it up on um
uh instagram if we're not connected over
there
dm me if you got a question i try to be
as active as possible
sean cannell rhymes with youtube channel
and uh that's over at sean cannell on
instagram listen
this is gonna be the best decade on
youtube i get it competition's rising
um i get it you know it feels hard to
break through
but if you look at the numbers 2.3
billion monthly active users you look at
the youtube economy the creator economy
um the amount of creators that are
doing this full-time it's the fastest
growing small business type
you look at what troy's doing and i
forgot if if troy
was still listening to this i would also
be doubling down besides all the youtube
stuff we talked about
tick tocks working for him and for his
brand and what he's doing i'll be
leaning into emerging platforms
we're just living through an era of
massive opportunity the thing is friends
opportunity is missed by most people
because it's dressed in overalls
and it looks like work and if it feels
like there's
a daunting mountain ahead it's because
it's going to take some work it's going
to take some grit it's going to take
some perseverance there's going to be
times when you want to quit
there's going to be times when you want
to throw in the towel there's going to
be times where you feel like you take
two steps forward
only to take three steps backwards but
those that are going to
dominate youtube over the next decade
are going to be those
that create a smart strategy take
massive action
and don't quit steve jobs said that
business is a game of attrition
what does that mean it means that a lot
of people will start
a business they'll start a youtube
channel but they'll just give up
so if you can simply outlast
others if you can simply if you can
simply stay
standing while others throw in the towel
a lot of people start youtube and they
go oh
this is actually challenging or oh i
don't think this would grow as fast as i
thought it would
that's when your grit muscle needs to
kick in that's when
your perseverance muscle needs to kick
in that's when
you got to keep punching fear in the
face keep
punching perfectionism in the face and
keep
pressing record i appreciate you i
respect you
and i really thank you for being a part
of this coffee with kennel episode it
feels good to be back
cheers until next time i'll see you in
the next video
check out the think marketing podcast
new episodes every tuesday
and in the meantime keep crushing it
keep smashing it and we will talk soon